It is absolutely an honor to be here today and I have to say it's also a little
daunting because I now have the job of introducing two
women who really need no introduction.
Gloria Steinem and Robbie Kaplan are two of my heroes.
Gloria has dedicated her life to women's
rights. Although some days she must feel like she's living in a time warp.
Robbie has helped change hearts and minds and laws on behalf of the
L. G.B.T. community. And even though they worked on different
issues at different times in different ways they have a lot in common.
Robbie and Gloria live at the intersection of women's rights. L G B
T rights human rights and so much more. And they
understand that when it comes to taking on injustice a lot of times
you don't pick your fights.
They pick you. We all know the story of E.T. Windsor
who married the love of her life only to be left with hundreds of thousands of dollars
in estate taxes after
her wife's death. Under the Defense of Marriage Act the federal government
couldn't recognize E.T.A. as a surviving spouse. When
Robbie Kaplan met E.G.. She heard a love story for
the ages and saw a once in a generation chance to end the Defense
of Marriage Act. She didn't
hesitate. She took the case.
And the rest is history. And thanks to Robbie
Kaplan So as DOMA.
Luu.
Now Gloria Steinem took up the cause of feminism at an early age after experiencing the many
ways in which the personal is political Since
then she's only become. More radical more
bold more funny
unapologetic and committed to lifting up women of all ages races and backgrounds.
She's taken on inequality in many forms and she's never
ever shied away from a challenge. No matter how insurmountable it
may seem now
I could stand up here and quote Gloria Steinem all day.
She is full of pithy wisdom as you're about to see. But my latest
favorite quote I have to admit of hers is in response to a journalist who
asked what will it take to elect a certain woman.
President of the United States. Gloria's
answer what it takes is us getting off our asses and vote.
So the truth is we're here together at an important moment and I'm not just talking
about the history I'm hoping will make next November at a time when L.G.B.
T. people are still subject to
discrimination transgender women of color are facing a
crisis that's literally a matter of life or death. When women's
reproductive rights are still up for debate. And we're still
arguing for something as fundamental as equal pay.
There's no doubt in my mind that we need Robbie Kaplan
and Gloria Steinem more than ever.
And I'm
so
so I'm so grateful they could be with us today
and that's who they are and what they represent to
me but we asked them how with day describe themselves.
Their
seven word bio if you will. So
Robbie Kaplan. Dome a Slayer a
dog with a bone. Gloria
Steinem. Writer organizer hope
aholic feminist humanist communitarian
and
dancer. Absolutely Fabulous. Please join me in
welcoming Robbie Kaplan and Gloria Steinem.
THANK YOU
THANK
YOU
THANK YOU so I'm a star I have I have a confession to make.
When I was in high school
all my mom called me up one day and said she had tickets to a book reading of
a book called Outrageous Acts and everyday were about me. And what I like to
go and so I went to a book reading for you in Cleveland
Ohio and I must to read this blog five hundred
times and
I had a little confessed to him looked at it until today and just looking at
the chapters. Again the chapters about how I was a playboy body.
I remember and the chapters.
I don't think could raise your head for this one if men could men straight. It's
almost it's funny the degree to which you know just
reading those words again brings back the memories I
had in the incredible admiration and inspiration I got from
you back in one nine hundred eighty three when I was a pretty
naive maybe a kid of early
feminists growing up in Cleveland Ohio.
Someone asked me to sign it again because I don't know if I can find my.
And you know I my I was talking earlier about
the show I think she's a word and it's right the intersection between feminism and gay rights and interests.
They're so intertwined.
For me growing up even though I think I had inklings for sure in
glimmerings that I was a lesbian the much bigger issue for me was
was being a woman and what I'd be able to leave would I be able to move to New York and be like
you what I be able to fulfill the dreams that I read in New York Magazine in Ms
Magazine that was a much bigger issue
because being gay I just figured I'd keep it in the
closet. And there were many years where being gay became a big
issue and
I think I've come full circle today for me at least being a woman is in a lot of ways
a tougher issue in the rarefied world that I live in them than being a lesbian
so my first question to you is you know how do you see that intersection. You know you
have a long record of this but how do you see the both the relationship in the way the two movements have kind of evolved
over time.
And my heart I think I don't see it as an intersection I see it as a circle. You
know and we're coming at our goal
of being unique humans and
also sharing our human. We're coming at that central goal from different
places but I would say it's like this not a hierarchy you know
like this and we are all linked. We're not ranked.
But what worries me sometimes is that I think our adversaries know
that somehow we all have the same adversaries. They know we're dealing.
But if you think about it in the most basic terms you can understand
why
because the whole idea of a male dominant or patriarchal or
or and or whatever you want to call it system is all about.
Trolling reproduction. I mean that is the basic thing. How
many workers how many soldiers who do they belong to then also if you
have race or class
or caste as in India then it becomes even more important to
control reproductions of that you can keep these groups separate and because it's
all about reproduction it demonizes any sexual expression
that can't end in reproduction.
So sex between two men between two women is terrible for the
same people who are against contraception or against safe and I pray you know everything
everything we know and it's just so important I think that we not see ourselves
in silos.
But we understand ourselves to be absolutely intrinsically
allied Absolutely. You know
I'm thing about if you're talking everyone so while the law. Can kind of recognize that
circle and it's actually just happened in this context because the Obama administration the
E.E.O.C. just took the position a couple months ago in states that
don't have protections for gay people civil rights
protections. You still can't fire again person from a job because it's sex
discrimination under Title
seven and there's this inherent realisation that even under the law
treating someone differently or because of sex. It's because A said.
Yeah I want to well the law catches
up.
You know I so admire that you have this crazy idea that
the law has something to do with
just
touch
the I've read this book and I tell you when
I when I graduated
from college. I kind of had this little idea that maybe I could be a lawyer.
Except that a lot of law school for exempting no women and Columbia are some very
liberal places accepting five percent
women. And my. Career
Advisor whatever's vocational advisor said Yeah well you could be a lawyer and you'd end up
doing a states and wills in the back room of you know no client or a
dead client. You
know. Or you could graduate and do research right away you know
so I never became a lawyer and I'm so proud of you are you not proud of this
one
hundred if I'm ever in jail. I'm calling you up.
I promise you I'll be there another one trillion. And I won't show you a paddy.
Oh I have a license to do a lot
of good you know the other thing we are I mean I think we
we have to cop to this right where two little girls from Ohio.
Who dreamed of coming to an icy other Ohioans holding
up their fists. The whole city of New York I think is former Ohio.
Who dreamed of coming to New York. I think New York is a symbol of freedom in all
kinds of ways.
And I am sure I've been in this room filling out little by hand.
Slips how many people remember this was the reading room. I think originally was
it and. Doing free research for some article
I was trying to get paid for so the ghost of that of our
former selves are here
too and you know I think it's so important to say that because
otherwise we in our earlier selves would look at us now and
say think there was some barrier that we couldn't do it but we
can and. I bet everybody here is a kind of you know those
Russian dolls. You know that are nested like
that so inside is our child self and our adolescent self
and right. And we're all here and it's OK we're.
I mean it's. And I would talk about this I mean that I do have this
amazing connection because Korea started a New York magazine right.
And then MS and my mother has this question to both and I remember in Cleveland.
You know really I couldn't wait for the new issue came to the
door and it of about the age of ten. I decided I was moving to
New York. No matter what and I was ridiculously logical about I was clearly going to
be a lawyer because I decided the way to do that was I go to school on these coast and I go to law school in New York
City and that's what I
did. A little scary quite frankly.
You know but reading your book I made
me feel.
You know because somehow your I don't I don't never met your mom so I'm going you know
but
anyway she was very part of the women's movement and reading mills
and doing all that but you didn't feel supported by her
and being who you are and saying you're a lesbian service. So that to me
is a shortcoming
of what she was reading. I feel kind of you know I
mean we.
We always you know I mean the very first issue
of Ms Magazine actually the editor of Newsweek at the time took me to lunch
and said OK the only way you can possibly succeed with a feminist magazine
is by making clear that it's a heterosexual feminist magazine against
the lesbian parts go you know. So naturally we had a huge lesbian article
first
so. We were trying but maybe we weren't trying hard
enough you know that was a society. I mean it is much as feminism was a
new thing that in founders I'm definitely inspired the early gay rights activism I've been reading about
it just recently Lilian faded man's book. I mean it was you guys you gave the gays
at Stonewall the gay people stonewall later the guts to do what they did
but I really think it you know it talks a society a
long time to come around. And it would have happened without the feminists doing what they were doing people would have
just stayed in the closet.
I think I think the shared.
Magic. It isn't exactly magic that ordinary magic is telling the truth.
You know and I think that the women's movement allowed women yet to
say here is my dream and I'm not doing it or I'm getting beaten up
at home or I'm not getting paid or whatever it is just telling the truth and that is the
source of all liberation movements really the one person tells
the truth
and then three others say you feel like that I thought that it was
only happening to
me you know it's always about you as you do that and you go around the world missed your book as you go around the world telling
the truth. Well I mean the one thing to tell the truth in the court romance
easy but also the way to
me You go everywhere in the world and tell the truth in
environments. You know I don't I don't I mean I get to listen you know.
And there's no magic greater than a circle of people telling their
stories listening to each
other everybody gets to talk everybody listens and I
think a great rule of political change is as simple
as that too
because if you are a more powerful person
in this particular situation whatever it is be sure and listen as much as you
talk and if you are less powerful Be sure and talk as much as you listen.
Which is sometimes even more difficult.
And you know that's the path. If you keep doing that organically
you'll you'll get
there OK So here's a question I have to ask you
so with within my lifetime within our lifetimes we've seen this incredible
change for gay rights we've also seen incredible change for women's rights. Seriously.
I never thought that I'd be able to do what I did I'm sure you never saw it growing up the Lido that you would
think you know I was trying to tap dance my way. That was the height
of my practicality if I learned how to tap dance surely I'll be able
to write. What what can the movements learn from each other and how
most importantly how can
we the incredible rate of change was just like a game might have been
extraordinary how can we accelerate women's rights and other groups rights the same way.
Well I do think truth telling is I mean for instance I mean the most obvious example
is abortion and in the first issue of Ms Magazine we have like I don't
know four hundred women who said well known women who said I have had an of it was then illegal it
was before the Supreme Court
ruling and I demand the decriminalization and so
on so you know one in three American women has needed
an abortion at some time in our
life and I think if we all came forward. It really came
forward. I mean the tactic of the right wing which is now move to state
legislatures since they couldn't get what they wanted to end a choice folks in
Washington and get a constitutional amendment and all that they moved to state
legislatures which they control for other reasons and
just you know the first they murdered what eight abortion doctors and then they were surprised this
wasn't popular so they stopped doing that.
Then and
now they're they're trying to do it through state
legislatures and there to if
we came forward and if we paid attention to
most Americans don't know who their state legislators are and
they are those are crucial because those folks are redistricting
themselves into perpetuity. Which is why the House
is Representatives is more difficult.
For the majority to win than the Senate you can't redistrict that state. You
know I think the path the path is
clear but. It may also have something to do
with sheer numbers.
Because everyone has lots of people have one of us at home.
The sort I was telling my dear friend
from Carlin who worked on the case with me tells a story about Rob Portman for a while so
the center from Ohio Rob Portman is very conservative man and he was
very anti marriage equality until one day he woke up and
his son said to him I'm
gay and it changes mine and I'm
not critical of that and that's the way people's minds get changed I think that's a good thing that he changes mine
but that's the problem is that he's not going to wake up one morning and find out his
father's African-American or needs a green card or probably not going to find out he has
a daughter who wants an abortion and it's that you're actually right it's that kind of truth telling
that kind
of that that creates the empathy I think that we kind of lost in
our
society and as. I'm trying to
think what his wife could say to him.
It's
you know is it just the sheer the sheer numbers make it make it hard
and also that women generally speaking still have two
jobs there still tend to be raising the kids much more though there are many more men who
are raising kids now
but it's still very very
unbalanced and it's it's just big and deep but
it will happen. I mean it will happen I. This may seem bonkers what I'm about.
But what helps me to know what will happen is that it was true in the past.
I think we study history in a way that causes us to
believe it's always been like this and it's human nature somehow and
it's inevitable but if you go back. Just five or six hundred years
here where we now are this is manna hatter this island when it
was you know before the Dutch and the English showed up it was a man I hadda. And that
meant that right here on this land there were.
Matrilineal cultures women and men were part of decision making groups women control
their
own bodies and decided when and whether to have children which they knew very
well how to you know they were incredibly easy gallop we would say gala Terry and they
didn't say that but nature
connected cultures that didn't even have words for he
and she in the language people were people mention
that. Or a word for nature because we weren't separate from nature.
So this may I don't know if this seems practical to you but it helps me to
know that ninety five percent of human history as far as we can
tell was different and so this
patriarchal nationalistic colonialist stick.
What
else heterosexist telephone homophobic.
It's bullshit monotheism monotheism I mean
if God is a man man is God You know I mean that came into being
for God used to be in everything in all living things
right until it was withdrawn from females and nature to make it OK
to conquer women and nature. OK I don't. This helps me I'm not
saying it but I
literally go out into Central Park and put my hand on those big outcroppings of
igneous rock and I think OK another hand was here and
people were living differently and I feel kind of intimate Lee connected to what I think of
his vertical history as opposed to horizontal history.
And I think in each human being is kind of what you're saying. She was being whether it's about a C. a stick
or not there's that spark of the divine and that we need to see that spark of the divine and in
each other again.
Yeah. In all of ing things really I mean that was that was. Maybe
not everywhere I don't know but I mean the quiet in the sun in Africa
the cultures of several hundred cultures that were
here and
India was there. It was there so we can do it in a new way.
OK I have to ask you about the the non elephant in the room. What Hillary
Clinton definitely not another don't tell you are really in the
realm which is I understand that in
the past you thought you were worried that she couldn't get elected to be the first
one president of the United States but you've come to change your mind and know who would know
better than you so tell
us why i love and I like your bronc I don't know I don't know anything
that we all don't know. OK the reason in two thousand and eight I thought
that she couldn't win. I mean you know first I supported them both and then
I supported Hillary because she was more experienced but they were the same on the issues so you know. But anyway.
But I thought it was too soon for her to
win because most of us are raised as
infants and little kids by women and we deeply associate female authority.
With childhood and
emotionality and you know nurturing and we don't
see women in that's already in the outside world so I think we almost when we
see an authoritative woman out there. We think
we can't. It's hard to get used to and. Some I think men especially
on television who the T.V. commentator actually felt
regressed to childhood when they
saw because they would
say things like oh I cross my legs whenever I see Hillary
Hello.
And there were some very serious bad stuff on campuses there were a whole lot of shirts that said
Too bad O.J. didn't marry Hillary.
You know. And only worn by white guys is in my
experience anyway. Right so you
know but now I think that there has been enough vision
of women in
authority in the world outside the home
that that it's going to be hell but I think it's I
think it's possible but I do not think we will be able to
really use all of our human talent until both men
and women are raising kids and both women and men are in the world. The rest
of the world.
I mean it's almost as if I mean I really it's almost as if though the first one present has to have probably the
best credentials ever right. I mean there's no presidential candidate ever who has a kind of background
the right is Hillary Clinton but that kind of makes sense
given no and she had to prove it again and again and again and again.
Right right right. You know absolutely. And though there is another
reason to to me too which is
that. Violence against women has now. I mean
females worldwide is so big so frequent.
In all whether it's son preference
or S.G.M.
or sexualized violence and war zones or honor killings or domestic violence
or whatever it is it all adds up to the fact that now there actually
are fewer females on earth and males for the first time I don't know that that's right.
So we really need to think about that. But
also what we what we also can absolutely
demonstrate is
that the biggest. Terminus of whether
or not somebody's going to be violence in the streets of a country
or internal to a country or that country is going to be willing to use
military arms against another
country is actually not poverty not access to natural resources
not religion or even degree of democracy it's a violence against females.
Because that's where we get the idea in the home that it's natural that one group dominates
the other to some degree and sometimes a huge degree and then we
think it's
inevitable and in the circle again because that's when you see the same kind of violence against gay
people right. The same countries where the lynching Game
Yes no absolutely it all it all the same absolutely goes
together and the reason I say that now is because I think
that that Hillary Clinton is the only person who would to my knowledge.
Who is running who would make that part of foreign policy.
Yeah you know who would understand that that is an important first person who made it by the foreman.
Well so yes in Beijing. She did her best to say I mean she said women's rights are human.
But you know the if if we had not
aided the Mujahideen who were overthrowing the
government and Afghanistan because why
because women were being allowed to go girls were being allowed to go to school
women were had to give their permission to get married and women could go to political meetings this is why
they overthrew the government in Afghanistan.
And we aided them. We gave them. We armed them
because we thought that government might be a little too friendly to the Soviet Union.
So I mean you know it's just it's crazy it's crazy not to include.
Half the human race in the way we think about for right now we included but we know it
would be nice. It's the end I would. Nice would be nice the girls go to school but it's
not serious you
know and again the same thing with you Secretary of State of insisting that not only are women's
rights human rights the gay rights are human rights. Yes coming out so forcefully for that and
making it clear that's not a question
of relevance. I think that she once left the White House and marched in the
gay march of some kind from the White House without a lot
of
it but I remember when she was running I mean I've been in a lot of gay pride parades in my time as you can imagine and
in the one that we won when Sir was incredible obviously and in writing with
either but equally I think is powerful was when Hillary was running for
Senate and she marched in for some reason I was marching very close
by and the role or when we went through the village. You know as
a Rhodes there I'll never forget that I mean I don't remember this being allowed only one Windsor It
was incredible and people got in there got that they had a champion.
OK But here's something I mean in the same way that I find it a miracle
that Hillary can withstand the amount of.
Opposition and tension
and. Spotlight And so I signed it a miracle that you could
stand there in front of the Supreme Court the Supreme Court.
I
mean you know. I was always I never spoke on public until
I couldn't publish what I wanted and I sort of inadvertently went out and started to say
but you as a kid you loved to talk according to your book right.
OK So but what did it feel like standing in front of those so
just so when you go
to records for people who've been there or have been it's
very formal as you can imagine and the room is beautiful and when you walk in and
you're facing the judges there's that's true there's this enormous red velvet
curtain and that you walk in the curtains closed and then the marshal announces that there can start the day in
the curtain
opens and Charles and the justices all come up.
And I remember when I started to speak I mean you can hear it on the tape. You know I'm a
little you know going through my brain was
like oh my God Oh my God Oh my God you know I'm just a Jewish girl from Cleveland Ohio What the hell am
I doing here.
But and it would be no different for you Gloria but pretty soon you know it was
just like OK this is like any other case it's obviously much more important but I've argued cases
before and I think in a crazy kind of way I guess I'm a little bear submit this
but when the justices kind of came at me the hardest it ended up motivating me
more and I remember thinking to myself OK you know I understand you don't agree with me I
understand you're a little irritated with me but you know what I'm from New York
City and I've argued against a lot of judges in my time who are more than
a lawyer to with me this is actually pretty mild by New York City standards
and it almost motivated me more the other thing I have to say is let me be
clear I've gone idea of whether this had happened but during the argument. I had been given
advice that I should look not shockingly to
Justices Ginsburg and Kagan
that if they thought that I needed help or they would I should look to them and I certainly
should agree with everything they
said and I should kind of float their way and it was very lucky they didn't ask
many questions that was a good sign I got almost all my questions from Justice Scalia sitting right there
and Justice Roberts right in front of me. CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS But at least
in my head I kept looking they both sit on the right and you're facing them I kept looking to my right and
just Kagan says all am I right. And this could have bit of my head I don't know if I was
hallucinating or not but I remember every time I looked to my right I'd see and I think to myself
OK Kaplan Kagan still smiling. You haven't screwed this one
up yet the
stuff Well I think. And again I don't get you simly anything to you but it was just such
a relief in my own head at the time and I was like OK you're clearly doing something
right or not asking any questions. OK that's that's the end. The
movie I think your book should be a movie.
Because. You know. It's
so incredible that it's the kind of thing that can only happen in real
life. It's could not possibly nobody would believe it in a novel
that you knew that you want to tell the story had a little getting of
the book suddenly this is the beginning of the movie but you could never get away with if
it was there to check and I want to believe it so I got this Con two thousand and
nine from a friend of a friend who said I know this woman by the name of any Windsor she had to be a
huge tax bill because Adama and she wants to sue.
And I had no I had never met eating WINSOR. But I knew
exactly who she was and she was not the celebrity she is
today some was not because of
that the reason that I knew is because eighteen years prior to
that I was in my third year law school and I had been I think it's fair to
say kind of a late bloomer in terms of coming
out I had thought about it in high school I thought about it in college
I certainly thought about it in law
school but I waited until the bitter end of my third year law school to kind of have the
courage to do or say
anything just my luck. Just as that was happening my parents were coming to
visit. My really bad luck I'd clearly done terrible planning its turns out
it was Gay Pride weekend so I was in this one bedroom apartment and
one room really studio partner in the Upper West Side and my parents coming to visit me had to kind of when
their way through the parade and by the time they got to my apartment they were in quite
a
state rules Messinger was on the Manhattan Borough president and her daughter marry him had been
Mike my college
roommate and so my mom kept saying oh I can't believe who's Messinger was leading the
parade what she proud of yatta yatta yatta I said to
my
parents stop and ask. And as mothers and daughters I want to do my mom continued.
And then I said the My mom said so why are you insisting that we stop. Are you
saying that you're gay and I said
yes and my mom kind of my worst fears became realize because my mom
walked over about three feet to the side of the the room and literally started hitting her head against
a wall. I'm
not it's not a Christian my mom my mom really has has apologized ten million
times for this and could not be more proud she's so excited that I was on the stage with you I can't even
tell you. But as you can imagine I was not you know I was pretty low
at the time and I went around asking in New York I need a psychologist the way you spoke back that
it was
good to gain issues and I kept getting the same name the name I kept getting with
the Aspire.
For those of you know who know I say here's a gas the U.S. buyer was in these files.
And I actually went to see her as a patient twice because I was moving to Boston at the end of
the summer twice in the very same living room that I then met EDI in in two
thousand and nine C. it was already paralyzed completely so she saw patients in her living
room and here's the craziest thing about it all is during those sessions she talked about
T.V. Now I'm not a psychologist obviously but it's my understanding the psychologist don't
really talk about their own personal
lives but I think Thea must a concluded and she was right about
this that the only way I was so low and I was so cynical that the only way she
could persuade me that I could have the life that I wanted is to tell me about her life.
So she told me about this brilliant mathematician who she been with E.T. WINSOR.
She talked about her being a brilliant computer programmer which she was she kept talking about eating when dreaming
Windsor and I again I only saw her those two times I would see her
after that in her wheelchair at the foot of their building during Gay Pride but I never approached her
and I was make sure she was there but I never poacher and then when I
it's two thousand and nine I'm in these apartments and I open up the door. And even though
I obviously knew where I was going all those emotions came right back
to me almost like going right back to the year one thousand nine hundred one when it happened and I
said to E.D. look I got to tell you I've been here before. Let me tell you why and
then the second thing I said to if you so don't look what I imagined you to look
like I
should think about you being a boy mathematician I thought you have like a slide rule and like a class.
I like
you are not the late the I describe you and that was the
beginning that we started the case that
day but I mean you know this is why life is so much
more weird than anything that could be said and thought was of it right. Can you see I mean you
wouldn't last it was true you wouldn't believe a movie in
which eight the first scene is eighteen years. You know and this
suffering young woman is coming to see a therapist. Who
then eighteen years later becomes the person who
dies and leaves her partner and in this case becomes a Supreme Court case
which is
that not a movie. I mean that's a but
it's the big question the play even thank you could make a play even.
And the other thing is I remember distinctly is thinking is I'm going to pay Thea back for helping me.
This is my
chance to pay Thea
back but it's just such an incredible
coincidence and you know in a way that's why I believe I mean we'd probably own good that's why I believe in
the divine. I don't believe it's
just coincidence I know it sounds sappy but there's got I mean I
believe there was something that brought us together something that we can understand is you know maybe
we put out by brave. We're at right I'm going for that but what if
what
it what it made me think of is
that in a way
that's what we share about the stories we're telling
is that if they were fiction no one would believe it. I mean the things
that one experiences me to. On the road and you know the people you
meet in the.
Crazy coincidence situations and and if you're on the road long enough it's like a novel
he made you know the person you haven't seen for forty years discovered some amazing
thing that
it's it's love I can't believe all you know what's
the saying that happened to you on the road most similar to that. Just most similar to that
other so many it's I know you didn't run into your psychologist on the
web
but
it's you know I will.
Here's here's just their thousand examples so I don't know but once I got an American
Airlines plane and there had just
been put off the plane
a African-American. I think they were still called stewardesses then I'm not sure if they
were yet flight attendants and the
pilot who was like many pilots an ex-military guy and so on
I had put her off the plane he had basically said he wouldn't take off until
she got
off because a she was she had an afro which you know
those you know they really regulate what flight attendants look like and
especially
them and be she was carrying a copy of Soul on Ice.
OK What year was this. Well it must have been the very early
seventy's might have been the end of the after the very end and it
got in the newspaper.
So I always remembered it you know and then of course
it's like thirty years later I mean I wasn't worth remembering it
anymore and I was someplace I think Seattle in
a radio station where the manager of the radio station was a woman which is
rare and she was showing me around you know.
In a great way and you know smart terrific woman.
And as I was about to leave she said Do you remember a story by
would put the last woman off you know because she had an F. And I said
Yes I've never forgotten. She said Well that was my husband I divorced
the
bastard and
Lucy said I went back to school and I'm doing this is I'm having a wonderful.
I
mean you know and. There
are I there are
thousands of stories like that that's just unbelievable and you just keep running
into them. You
know I mean I go back to a hotel someplace in
the Midwest after the whole campus event and I'm exhausted and so
on and in the lobby are like forty people
from the convention older
older African-American men from the Negro Baseball
League right. Who are having a reunion. Wow.
You know one guy's in a wheelchair somebody else offensive. So and I sat there for hours
listening to
stories that would be. Right I mean it just happens all the
time all the time. Once I was coming back from. A
Again a campus lecture and meeting in
Boston and I had to leave the very next morning for some odd place
and Africa I was going I don't know but anyway
the the kids.
I missed the last plane from Boston to New York for the kids got me a car.
With a driver to drive me home so I could sleep along the way and gave me a pillow.
But the driver said to me that he used to be a truck driver.
And. And we started talking about his truck driving and I did you ever see the
movie they drug by night. You know it's an old French. So I thought that's what it was. Like
that he
was he was homesick for this dangerous dangerous dramatic to say no
he said I miss the community. What do you mean the community you're driving by yourself isn't but me sure.
Anyway we stopped in every truck stop.
All night long
between New York and the between was Boston and New
York and I discovered another world there is a whole world that is alive
at night. There's there's music songs that are truckers
songs that you know are incredibly popular and maybe we've never heard them.
There's a whole system in which you said at the counter and you can get a slab of lemon meringue pie a
cup of coffee and a motor oil can a motor oil all
of the same time in which order.
There are worlds out there there are two worlds and if you just go with it that's the on the
road state of mind.
Actually you know it's interesting I was just as I was reading
your book an edge of time the story I remember this year actually during
the the Jewish New Year my my friend and Rabbi Jenner back gave a whole series of
teachings about the concept of home in exile and the point that she was trying
to make which she says is very she thinks is very much part of our tradition is
that oftentimes you have to go into exile in order to find
home that traveling in seeking is part of the human condition.
And that we all have fun around why did she say exile I wonder why mission time about
the metaphor of Jews as being an exile and whether that was a bad or good
thing and that in this idea I think
that home is a place that you have to many of us have to search for right.
We have to tell our truth and we have to search for our homes and only by traveling and going
on can we do
that you know that that is more my experience of course because I
haven't suffered exile in the way that was massively suffered
but what I've done. Covered over time I think is
that it's not settling down or being on the road I mean in
this case it turned out that my parents kind of represented I hadn't thought about it
but my mother never had a journey of her own.
At least not after I was but she had earlier in her life but I didn't know
that and my father who lived in his car. We lived in the house trailer never had a
home and it took me a long time in my own life to realize that the
whole point is to have both you and I don't think we're told that you know we're told we have to
settle down or with you know and I think we but you know because just
from our the our genes you know we've
been following the climate
following the animals forward but with our group and our yards and
our whatever. So we we all need
to be on the road and to have a home both I think in a kind of
balance completely should we is
a time yeah I DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME IT IS WHAT TIME IS IT. We want to hear from you. We can't see you very well
but we want to hear.
And
we're bringing bring in the light you are proud right but don't be shy and I could take questions
from Justice Scalia I can probably answer yours.
And
if you don't you don't have to ask questions you can give us answers that would be very good.
You
can also make announcements of you know whatever outrageous things. We need to know
about and we encourage everybody to come up here and line along this center
line and. Please speak and the microphone. Thank you.
Whenever I see this it shows my child I would think of Phil Donahue know him as like it's my
lifelong dream of being on the Phil Donahue
Show. Hi Thank you for
coming from honor to be here.
I I wanted to say you have a. A definite philosophy
about women having control over their own bodies and that that gives
women independence and
freedom. But you know
up and yet that has occurred.
And women are still not making earning as much as men
and I happen to be in the banking world and. You know in terms
of women progressing at the same rate of men the way women are seen
the way women leaders.
How difficult it is for them and that's just thinking I think was
the same right in terms of women actually being acquitted partners in a law firm
and that's pretty rare. So it seems like that's not the
only answer. You know and
I'm I'm not saying you have to have the answers.
But where did the women's movement go and what happened to and why are
people talking about these issues that's one and two why
wasn't there a huge outcry when Henry
Clinton with interviewed for a Levin straight hours.
I mean why have there if you're
right it wasn't you. And I couldn't believe
that everyone was an outrage by that she was abused publicly.
She's running for president. I mean so I guess my main question is what happened to
the women's movement we arrested. It's right here its word hello was a member of the realm of the
oppressed Thank you Lou.
Now it's never enough whatever it is this is never enough but the E.U. know the
a gale Collins is you who is she here someplace now. But anyway she wrote
a brilliant New York Times op ed page
piece about those eleven hours in which Hillary look
presidential and you know serve as a guest.
You know so. I mean I think people were pissed at the committee for their treatment and
their waste of money my God they wasted millions of dollars on this Benghazi
but that actually the balance
was mainly on behalf
of you know I feel or my sense is a certain point of time she knew that she had it and she was like
OK go on you can just give
us some more stupid question to ask B. is yeah I said and then putting the beef be
my guess
it turned out it turned out to be an
advantage as as for either women controlling
our own physical selves from the skin and I mean that's that's not the only
thing that's just a basic thing because whether or not you can decide when and
whether to have kids is the single
biggest
element in whether you're educated or not whether you're healthy or
not whether you work outside the home or not and how long you
live so it is a fundamental human right to just
for all of us men and women the power of the government stops at our skins I would say. Could we
do you think you could make this
principle on about only integrity next OK OK no problem. Well I'd like to order up
a principal cause the IFTIKHAR I mean you know when i'm thing about it is the concept
of kind of the
a keenness factor that used to exist with respect to gay people we've got rid
of right. Pretty much or in a lot of American culture not everywhere but
we've certainly made huge strides and it's it's different for women but
we need to make those same strides and it's not just about integrity it's about
how we're seen and how we're perceived and what people expect from
us say it's really the same thing it's
just we've got to figure out how to do it the way we did it with respect to get it
right and we have to do all kinds of things in order
to demand equal pay which of course we do not have
and Wal-Mart and all kinds of big corporations are making a fortune. Off the underpaid labor
of women and
having women present I mean I hate to sound sappy but it will have a huge impact I mean how many little girl
I mean I never thought there'd be a woman president when I was growing up so that will have a huge impact
on not only all the kids growing up there but the way
people see women right. But anyway in answer to the one who asked
Where is the women's movement. Give us your e-mail.
How
do you every single.
Now. Definitely not now
but the great thing is about goals is that their dreams you
move forward right and you keep getting new ones.
And you meet such great people along the way like you.
Me.
During.
I was wondering where this was.
When you were originally and I was going say
it's making me it's so painful to watch and
scary when you originally set out.
What gave you the
inspiration that you could
have the change that you would. And if I
can ask you for you.
What's
been what's been the impact of
MS over time. Do you mean the magazine or your form of address
or Oh the letters.
Well what what gave me the idea was just.
Realizing that I wasn't by myself you know what we were saying you know telling the truth about our
lives finding that somebody else felt the same way well. Hello. Maybe if
we do X. and Y. You know we can move forward to
get you know I think we're communal animals I don't think we can do it by
ourselves but. But you know together we can do
it and what's been the impact of MS You know we get
we hear stories of people
who saw the first cover
about battered women and started a shelter or we or
the my the piece we did the that turned into a
movie or this I mean those are all you know there's tons of.
Of stories that we hear but I suspect that those of you in the audience
know better than I do you know what it's incorrect but it's still the
only magazine for women that's controlled by women and it
is the only one that isn't influenced by advertising.
So is you may notice in other women's magazines especially because their
catalogs even though the editors are always trying to get something in there.
The articles are mostly about product.
And we don't have to do that in fact we've lost fiction and poetry from women's magazines too
because of the advertisers won't pay to be next to it so. So we haven't had as
much impact as I would like but I think we've had quite a lot of impact.
So in the movie Truth which everyone should see there's the scenes about Dan
Rather leaving
C.B.S. actually also a movie about sexism. But there's a scene when the young
reporter talk to Dan Rather and he said What got you into journalism and Dan Rather
said Kerik says curiosity and he turned to the young reporter and said look at you into
journalism and he turned to the guy and says You got me into journalism.
I did what I did because when I was a young kid growing up in Cleveland Ohio in the suburbs
I read Ms Magazine.
So there you have
it one. Thank you Fredricka.
Why it's so great to have you both on this stage together and really mind
blowing actually and I have a question for our Because you're both up here and want to highlight for
each other and Larry's happening
earlier about how we're not ranked we are linked and I do believe that I would love to be a
helper holic but the civically around abortion and
getting more allies to support in this kind of work
I wonder how how we move forward because I keep seeing political issues being
very diluted like if you're going to vote you have to vote on this one thing and if you are going to give money have to give money
to this one thing and all these issues are really
connected. And for women I think that abortion can be a key to many more of these issues.
And I would love to hear how you think we can move forward.
Well I mean I do see you know truth telling and understanding that
reproductive freedom reproductive justice is a fundamental human right.
Like freedom of speech or anything else.
So you wouldn't vote against some vote for somebody who is against freedom of speech so you know
just treat it like a fundamental human right that a true truly is and that means
the freedom to have children as well as not to have children you know it
really is both
things. Telling the truth voting giving money.
I don't know I dedicated my book to an
abortionist and I'm glad every day. Because I
may be a. Maybe I should explain what I mean by that what I meant.
Because it was kind of it's quite personal women know because I
think we have to tell the truth personally right.
OK This book is dedicated to Dr John Sharp of London who in one nine
hundred fifty seven a decade before physicians in England could legally perform an
abortion for any reason other than the health of the
woman took the can. Literal risk of referring for an abortion a twenty two year old
American on her way to India.
Knowing only that she had broken and engagement at home to seek an unknown fate
he said you must promise me two things first you will not tell anyone
my name. Second you will do what you want to do with your
life. Dear Dr Sharp I believe you to know the law
was unjust would not mind if I say this so long after your death.
I've done the best I could with my life this book is for you
and
you'll
thank you Lou that's my thank you
that's that's my story and but you haven't you all
have. Unique stories we need we need to you to tell your story.
Hi I thank you both so much.
So this is looking to you both for advice with them. For
me and my other fellow twenty one year olds whatever way of college
and
havening are hopeful activists and what we can do to use our power
and our privilege and our energy fully to effect the most positive
change you
think you know I think we you know some to me like you're probably already doing
it number one number two you know I think we have to work we have to find allies we have to
work together. It's not a coincidence that the same Republican presidential candidate
who thinks there should be abortion even in the case of rape or incest things that the
worst Supreme Court decision of the last hundred
years was over the father marriage equality incision in Windsor.
So we know who's on the other side and we need to work together with the groups on our side to
have common cause to convey. And ourselves and
then the rest of this country that we're on the right side of
history that I mean the two most obvious powers we have our
vote power. I mean the voting booth is the only place on earth where the
least powerful and the most powerful are equal. OK there's no other choice that
we have to remember to use it and we have a very low voting rate in this
country and dollar power. You know those are two but I think we
worry too much about what should we be
doing and the answer is and the thing you can
every day. It doesn't matter little or big Just everything we
can all be honest with you there are nights. Maybe this is a sign of age but it's
embarrassing fact that with you know
those so much tougher than I am but there are nights when I go to bed and I've had a tough day and I'm like
oh you know can I really keep fighting all the times I really want to keep fighting like
this the rest of my life and then I wake up the next morning and at the thought is gone and whatever
the fight is that day I go fight
it. That's all we've got to do each and every day. And a
little dancing after fighting. That's
the.
Heights of a great honor to be here. First I just want to say to you that I was a teenager in the one nine
hundred seventy S. and I was a very young feminist and the impact on my life that you
had is so enormous that I had not just advantages
but I knew I can do and be whatever I wanted to do and be in my life because of you.
So the question I really have is about the term is the title Ms because for
me it was so exciting that women weren't going to be known by their marital
status and I don't think that's changed my sister in law said to me not long ago that
she thought her MS was for divorced women and as I raise my son.
Mrs for the single women and Mrs All the teachers are Mrs except the single
teachers and their Mrs.
So I just behooves me and. Fifteen Is that still the
case a mine site. In the seventy's but it wouldn't be that
way. Well it's it was never meant to be imposed just there as an
option I think what's happening is a lot of people don't use any form of dress at all
you
know mess Mrs A but MS actually is a
very old term from I don't know those fifteenth century of the fourth or something
in England that it was you know even kids were known as mistress
and master right. So it was an abbreviation that just meant female
without marital status and we put it out there as an
option and Bella Abzug you know made it a congressional bill so the
government had to offer it as an option to bellow I Wish You Were
Here.
So it is an option but I don't think.
We let me just say is one of the oldest people in the room.
It's not like it used to be that you had to be a Mrs or it was a disgrace.
You know that you. Or the Mr or Mrs You know I mean it used to be so
much worse.
But now it's just much more open to options of what you want to call yourself.
I do think it would be helpful though if people
who have kids name you gave them both last names.
Of their parents because
otherwise. Otherwise people are walking around as we speak saying this is my child when I
first married. This is my child. Then we know who their parents
were what their parents were
but but then they can choose whatever name they want when they get to be eighteen. That would
that would work better within the age of computers. You know you'd have
individualized names. I mean I would say languages and really important and one words we
use and in the brief in Windsor I was obsessed that we not use the phrase.
As a homosexual heterosexual because my view was if you're comfortable with a gay person
you don't say oh there's that homosexual couple cross the
street you say the gay guys across the street and so you know I was very clear on the other
hand my wife is sitting right over here and I tell you we find using the phrase wife kind of
liberating I mean you know first I was a spouse and it was kind of this people didn't really get what I was talking
about and I'd be like oh
here's my wife Rachel in the crazy kind of counterintuitive way
that itself was liberating So I think the one thing we know about language is it has a lot
of meaning and. We have to think about what language we're using and what we want to lay with
that and then we each get to pick I mean I was thinking when you were saying that the you know
I was married for three years and we could never say husband and wife
because we were male and female it was just too like giving
in so we used to say the friend I married.
Oh.
Thank you both so much amazing to hear you both.
Hi
I'm an Australian career driven
litigator to want to holiday I didn't know and did met a New
Yorker and never having thought I want to get married got married a month ago or and I'm now in New York
US are hearing you guys talk about travel and exile and finding yourselves a very appropriate for
me right now. But as an
outsider in this city trying to find my community and listening to you talking about truth
telling I feel very much like this is a city
where it's very segregated. At least for
an outsider coming in and I want to hear stories and I want to listen and I want to learn
and. My experience of the Internet at least is that we heard at the beginning
about transient transgender women of color and that seems to be a
huge flashpoint at least on the Internet when you want to hear about a story because transgender women and women of
color are by feeling at least in that space very
exiled from the feminist movement and I find New York a place where it's very different
difficult to listen or. Even find communities to listen and so I just wondered if you could speak to
how we listen
properly and how we listen in this city
or people that are white women of color as much as I love listening to you very. I
mean why women
and I mean how do you find your community here saying.
How do I say how do I listen
to people that I just not in my community because if I if I really want
to properly do that listening to truth telling I want to hear the truth telling
of difference as well and I find that very difficult to access.
Well that's a that's a big question and I'm as an organizer
tempted to say.
Tell me what you're interested in give me your email and we'll try to find you the right. You
know I don't know if
that's practical or not but it's here I just want to tell you it's here and you know it's here
it's probably in this room. You know I always try
to say to people the before you go. Introduce
yourself to at least four other people you don't know.
In the room. You know because if you came here you probably share interests and values
and you know you could end up with a new
friend a new love affair or a new job and who knows just
from tonight. You know from introducing yourself. So try
that
but seriously if you if you if you say just tell me what your interests are and I'll try
to
be a bridge. OK thank you I mean I actually think this is heartening I mean I think the internet
is amazing and it's made. Life so different and so much more efficient and.
Giving people access to knowledge and so money incredible ways but I think it also can alienate
people and I
think we lose we're losing touch with the value of face to face yet a reaction.
And so the factor of so many people are here and we're having this conversation. Is a good thing we have to make sure we
don't lose the art of that.
Yes and I'm so glad you said that because I asked my
friendly neurologist. If the. Oxytocin
the tendency of you know what allows us to empathize with each other is produced on the screen
or the page.
And she said no you have to be present with all five senses.
So impressing sound is not doing anything either because
even if you click a
lot.
Hi
So my question or a similar question to mine was
already asked so I just want to take the time to say thank you to both of you I think both
the movements that. You guys have both been so involved with just have been so inspiring and have
given me so much joy just like a small example of that I watched
incredible documentary.
Last winter called She's so beautiful and she's angry about the second wave feminism
and I
had this smile plastered on my face the entire time because as hard as these types
of movements. Are there just there's so much joy in that community and
the people striving for like what is
right and I just went home and tore through all these like books about women's history and like that kind
of brought me to like discover my history and so I'm just like
thank you thank you very much. OK When I write
the SO BIG Do you know the woman from Australia who just spoke.
The Thank You to each other.
OK. Thank
you
so I mean and this Mike is very tall hat and my name
is Meyer Bernstein shallot I'm seventeen and
my mom got married this summer after twenty seven years of being together.
Thank you just wanted to thank you thank you thank you because that
made a huge difference in my life. And my family's
life on a separate note I'm really interested as a young
person about what you were saying about the liberating power of truth telling.
And I'm wondering what you would tell your seventeen year old
selves knowing now that you had a life ahead of you of liberating truth
telling what advice would you give
yourself.
I would give my advice to give myself the advice of my grandmother gave me which
is trust your gut always do what you think is right it's sometimes going to
be scary but that's the only way to live your life. And I was I was lucky enough
to have a grandmother who told me that and that's was good pretty good advice.
What
would I say to my seventeen year old so I guess I would say
it's going to be all right.
Thank you.
Hello
my name is Sophie I'm also seventeen and a daughter of two
women lawyers and there's nothing wrong with that.
Yeah thank you. And they've definitely inspired me to go into law myself.
So this was kind of a more legal question
but how do you think the court should continue to interpret the Constitution
such that it leads to further into human
rights over to fall where we were granted the right
to marry. Look I mean you know the Supreme Court is
very dependent who the justices are on the Supreme Court and big cases like Windsor and over
the fell. There's gave a great quote a Justice Kennedy said case
a swing I don't
but he is the vote that decides cases and it's always very important and
he has this concept that he's
developed really coming from world view. Wade of human
dignity in the importance of respecting human dignity under the Constitution.
He himself has he said it today. Has has said that he is certainly interested I
think in applying that in other areas. Certainly with respect to. Incarceration.
People who are in prison and. Really have no access are in solitary confinement no access to people perhaps.
In connection with the death penalty that remains to be seen there are a lot of other
issues that need that that principle has to be applied so I'm just being realistic with this court right
now I think those are the two most promising
areas but we need to go you know much broader than that and we need to make sure.
Again going back to what Gloria said that we elect politicians who put justices on the Supreme
Court who will honor. Those principles and will continue to extend
them as in to future
generations and I think I mean you know this better but I think if we had an Equal Rights Amendment
absolutely in the Constitution if women were actually in the Constitution.
We would I think for instance we wouldn't have lost the class
action against Wal-Mart. Absolutely
because as it is we have to prove intent we have to prove
state of mind. Another word the discrimination was present massive
factual provable. But it's very hard to prove state
of mind. And that's what we're producing these people write a memo and look at who wrote
what in that opinion who wrote the dissents look at the gender of the
justice right to dissent in the Wal-Mart decision and it was just its glory is absolutely
right thank you so much.
First thank you so much for being here you're both such fears of mine. It was actually a paper I wrote in tenth grade
on Windsor inspired me to go to work and
activism something I'm wondering as I'm going to notice of a teenager even growing up
in New York City is that the way that I have learned
about human rights and about activism is it is a lot through the Internet and
through discussions and things I read on the Internet. How do you think that both the old G.B. team.
Plus men and women's rights movements can work either individually or together
to use the Internet or technology tool for affective activism.
I think word. A lot of people are doing it already right I mean the just.
Huge waves of publicizing something that's wrong that gets fixed
because everybody had access to pooling
this information that never otherwise would have gotten in in
the regular media you know I mean there are people in
this room. You too you probably know better about how to organize on the web and
mean.
It's so you know I would just say.
Make sure that what's on there is accurate because there is no big fact checker in the sky which
sometimes makes me nervous about
science and also remember as you were saying that all five
senses are still know the and we the best use of the Web is
to figure out how to meet and how to actually
act and also remember that it is a little economically divisive because
not everybody has access to technology globally not
everybody is literate and the big majority of people who are not literate
are females I mean we we can't so fall in love with technology that we don't forget that
it
is sometimes divisive. I mean here's the here's my dream. This is my dream.
We have a
satellite. Which broadcasts and talk every
language and on the ground we have wind
up radios you know those you don't even need electricity for right. And you don't need to
be literate you can get I mean you know we need to keep on democratizing technology
too and I think it's Leeson the L.G.B. team is the most
effective organizing that was on the web. The kind that really told people
stories and then showed the humanity of what we were doing and not just the
abstract principles and we have to see each other's
humanity. Thank you so much.
I have a similar question just wondering like as a seventeen year old queer girl.
If you have any thoughts on the federalization of lesbian sex like as
an intersection of the marginalization of women and like the old you need to commute.
Well I'm the wrong person to answer this question I'll tell you why so at the beginning of the case.
We had a press
conference with the Windsor and I was in a room like this and someone asked
her a question. Saying it was a perfectly good question and said you know you and you were
together forty years. What was the secret of your
success said keep it
hot and then she proceeded to kind of go into
this some detail about how to
time and after the she did
that in the you have to remember buying why but I took her aside and I said Look E.D.
I said we have to think about this case in terms of who our
audiences and our ultimate audience are nine justices of the Supreme
Court and I don't really want them reading I think I
said I don't want Justice Scalia reading about your sex life in your boats in fam
rolls before the case gets decided I
said after the cases aside you can say whatever you want. I don't care but while this case is
pending you have to agree with me that you're going to then she great she followed her
into the bargain the day the case was decided all
right she said to me all bets are off and they were all off
so I definitely played the role of the prude in our relationship ended up working out pretty well.
So if you have a question I suggested you have to be winter and I guarantee you should give you a very
detailed
answer. Thank. Thank you. And I'll be
happy to do so for you but
I want to be there. What she had to say.
Good evening my name is Vanda and I wrote down my question while
standing in the line as I tend to be nervous. While speaking in public.
So I came to New York all the way from Prague Czech Republic which is a country
that suffered for half of the past century under the tile the tearing communities
regime where we've been told that all animals are equal but some animals equal.
And because of that old grew tired of talking about equality as a desire.
So many of them in Central and Eastern Europe has a long way to go and the fight for gender
equality is especially difficult in a society that label seventy S. movement.
As yet another ideology that wants to tell people what to do. So what will
be your piece
of advice for feminists from a ready young democracy that is still struggling to
find distinct voice and I'm talking both about myself and my
country.
That's so big I don't think I mean I think you know so much more. Yeah of
the I mean I would trust your instincts about what to
do but funny you were saying that I was just thinking that you
know Marx and Engels were inspired
by the Iroquois Confederacy
here and that was their idea
of first idea of primitive it wasn't primitive but anyway communism.
So and they unfortunately kind of left out the woman part somewhat
although
Engels was better than Mark.
So I think
it's partly understanding that the forms of equality that
were present in that system were not really the.
Forms that you want right.
So in a way the very word equality got devalued.
So again as to its telling the truth telling
stories organizing together. I mean you know
there's there's no there's no substitute for that.
But what do you think should happen. I mean wouldn't.
I sense that you
know so much
but. I definitely do not
have the right answer if I would have
the answer I wouldn't be standing in the light for ten minutes.
I mean as being part of the feminist movement in the Central
and Eastern Europe and fighting fighting against
a backlash within the mainstream
society where people would say things such as oh you know let people
decide whether they want to lead a parent decide whether they want to go
and spend some time with kids at home. As if there would be
no structural you know.
Inequalities that will force women to you know. Spend more time like cats
and not building the careers. I have
to say that you know we look both the U.S. and North of
the Europe for inspiration and you know we just keep on
fighting because if we sort of believe that it will get better because it can
get any worse.
I mean it's not shows like it but I mean it's been very inspired by the woman who just won the Nobel
Prize who I think she's in either Ukraine or Belorussia I can't remember which
who's really a truth teller and has she was the first journalist to credit when
the rebels right here. So there are women out there but it's hard I know
that. Yeah I would say that the most difficult thing would be to convince people that.
The truth telling is really truthful. So maybe
that's the hard part but anyway. Thank you thank you.
Firstly thank you so much for always
including even using that as a verb in the life of your
career the inclusion of everybody has been so remarkable
the gospel of inclusion.
You know not just women and men and black and white but everybody.
So I have three yes or no yes or no questions we get through this really
quickly like a cross-examination
and I and other than you if you have it the first one is your two years in India.
Is it's at the basis for how you were able to deal with them
in Detroit the basis of how you were able to with
such great deal with the admin in Detroit for example you didn't like go
and try to kill them or
anything you
actually. Brought them in it at that crucial time when you were that's so
interesting because I mean that's trying to sell ads in Detroit for Ms Magazine flashes
before my head before my mind
I don't I don't know if I I mean India. It
taught me how to organize all it took me a long time to figure that out because I didn't I came
back thinking that India had no application here and took me along right.
But
you know I I just gave up on Detroit
actually I mean that's why you
still had really difficult interactions with people and from what I've
read which is a sense of is it that you were never a jerk. You know
you weren't like I mean you. You know you
were really looking at the person not to
be honest I think here's what saved me always OK. No one could
fire me.
OK. So you have. I think all. Yeah no I think all movements need a
certain percentage of people who who who can't be
fired who are independent organizers so much. If my livelihood
had dependent depended on those guys in Detroit it would have been very
different but I could say things that the women who work for them couldn't.
And then I could be in cahoots with the women who work for them and find out in Seville you know I think
we all have have different roles to
play
but you know I've done some pretty terrible things at the
enters the house
and I wasn't always so Gandhian about the whole
thing and I'm not even talking about that I mean he had his
problems too I mean you you you seem to have had
a
spiritual you know I don't know whether it was in dealing with them or the Midwest you know I
come right you
know where Ohio and what that means is you have to be on L.S.D. to know whether we're
having being angry.
OK So that was your demeanor all along and I'm just reading into it right
now and then your i'd definitely didn't do yes or no I was sorry
I got that I got it so that the one hundred seventy seven. Do you think in Houston.
If you
had let's say. Equalize the.
Rage or play with Phyllis Schlafly that. If you
had gone to her level of trickery. That would
or would know. I don't think so this is the national conference in Houston which is
in the book and is like the most famous meeting nobody knows about you know because it really gave the women's
movement massively our agenda of issues and and so
on and you know would we if I if we had behaved
like fellow Shockley would we. Have the equal rights of women no because it was
really an economic interest against it so us laughing was just a window dressing room.
It was really the insurance
industry. One of the last I think the last industry
not controlled federally but can troll state by
state and they didn't want to equalize their actuarial tables that would cost
them a lot. They had to do it by race. It would be much worse if they had to do it by sex
they didn't want to do it and that's why we lost Equal Rights Amendment. It was you know Phyllis
Schlafly was kind of the window dressing. But it's
still there I mean we still have your a but it's super
under Yeah and we have to go back and get the right.
Franken. All right I'm just going to
leave it.
Just in the interest of time we're going to end the line at the very end there.
So all of you will get to ask your question well just so you keep it brief please thank
you and we'll try to answer shorter.
Hello. I'm a recent law school graduate and I do believe that the law can bring justice.
I focus on reproductive justice and I'm much too nervous to form a coherent question for either of you.
So I'm standing in a room full of feminists I would like to just briefly give voice to an issue that I
think many families perhaps most eminent don't even know is going on in this country which is the
widespread criminalization of pregnancy I would call it. I'm talking
about
court ordered to scary in
sections arresting pregnant women because they allegedly use marijuana and that's going to harm the
baby harm the fetus.
It's based on the same idea that the anti choice movement is based on the idea that the fetus can
have rights that outweigh those of the woman
carrying it. I so I just want everyone to know about
that and you can learn more at an organization where you
say in turn National Advocates for pregnant women.
Yes that is a great organization thanks to all advocates for pregnant women is
a great organization that's absolutely true that women are in jail as we
speak because the fetus is valued more than they are and they are.
Right it's completely and constitutional but it's happening.
Thank
you very well thank you so
much both for being here tonight. I just want
to say that I felt very inspired and
your comment really resonated with me that Gloria. And the voting booths were
all equal and I just wanted to raise that.
Next month. Elizabeth Cady
Stanton the organizer of the first. Women's Suffrage conference in
eight hundred forty eight will be celebrating her two hundredth birthday and.
She won't be
here. I want to thank you so I would have given her a birthday
gift but.
Instead to celebrate her birthday and the spirit
that runs through you
to give you her birthday gift.
You know it's a shirt. And it. It's kind
of symbolic for the women in the world
who and humans in the world don't actually have the right to vote. So
this comes from China.
The translation is this is what a feminist looks
like it's trying to use all that for all if that happens. Oh
thank you so much.
Thank you
I thought thank
you that's over and I saw these on the web and I cover
the rest thank you thank
you and just tension I
should let the kids stand is my great great great grandmother.
Wow
thank you I should add that was what we're all equal we get into the voting voting the. There have been
my way too many sometimes successful efforts like a local
power to block people from getting to
the right
Andy thank
you I just the Krillitanes living in Brooklyn no famous great
great grandmothers
so.
For all the really quick Hispanics I think I can speak through this.
First I just want to say thank you so much I'm so excited to see you both here and especially Gloria for
I don't know how many times like you answer the question by asking the person to look to their own power which I
think makes you such a bad
ass and really quick for the Australian woman if you're looking to hear
the powerful truth. Of trans women of color right here in New York City. I recommend Sylvia Rivera Law
Project Audrey Lord project Community Health Care Network and I bought houses like the godmother
of all trends at the nose living in New
York. It's right here you can take the F. crane what to stop the
Twenty third street I promise you we're here. OK. Two
questions and it's one for each of you like a grand prize here.
OK So you said our vote and our dollar that was your answer
to what we can do and what hope do we have what hope can you give us with
how much our goal in our dollar has
been devalued and decimated by corporate interests who get so
much more of their vote and their dollar in our
politics today and follow up for you. You being
the amazing constitutional lawyer that you are what hope do we have to see a
change in the case law that led up to Citizens
United which really was just the final coffin. I mean the finally on
the coffin of case law that really perverted the thirteenth Amendment. What do you see as the hope
for future case law
to overturn that case. Thank you
for introducing this in the United I
mean it has a majority on the court. I think it was a five four
decision just. I said before that means there's one judge who essentially is
voting swinging the
case and in order to change that we need to have another
judge be the swing vote in that
case. And that depends goes right back to the voting booth. That's plans on who's president and who
they nominate to be on the Supreme Court there are people on the Supreme Court right now for getting on
in
age and they're going to be retirements and we need to make sure that the best candidates
replace And there's also the possibility of Congress passing of a Congress passing
something this Congress is going to pass anything but there's certainly the chance of Congress trying to do
something but both of those fronts are very important.
You know we're certainly shamefully economically divided and you know we don't have
to go into how terrible that is but it's also true.
And I've seen it happen. That organizing and getting out the vote
can defeat money.
It can get to be television ads can defeat. You know it's a lot of
work but it's absolutely possible
and worth it.
So you know we have to start where we are and that's that's what we're
that's what we've got and we need contagious movements
Occupy is contagious black lives matter is
contagious. It changes
consciousness and I feel in you the ability
to change consciousness. Thank
you Thank you Lou.
Good evening. Gloria and there there been a few things you said this
evening that have really resonated with me it would be that you see you look at the rights that
you fight for and you characterize them as human
rights you talk about the linkage of the issues so that it's really no one pitted against the
other that it's a self reinforcing
circle. Gloria you spoke about the linkage to nature and how oftentimes a way in which
we look at society now it breaks that.
And then sort of reflecting on the fact that you speak about though the work that you do is represented
representatives of movements. I work in the climate change space. It's a pretty
big year in the climate change
space and we're sort of at a tipping point of no return if we don't take the actions
now we might we do and and in despair. I hear the voices
of the youth movement standing up and being counted. I hear the voices of the
poverty movement doing the same here from try unions
and not to take away from you know voting power against money I
actually also hear from the corporate movement. I'd be really really really gratified to
hear from the two of you here on stage what they L.G.B. team movement and what
the agenda right. The tennis rights movement could contribute to this issue
because it's an issue that essentially effects everybody. And it's an issue that needs to be
addressed now.
I mean Act I could agree with you more I think you know I think there are people I mean you have the pope is your ally which
is a good thing. I mean his and circled on this is beautiful when we have issues with other things
he says and does but he's beautiful on climate change and we have to use that and we all have to we have to get a
broader coalition as
possible and convince the rest of this world that you know
this this planet is a
gift. And we have to honor that gift and respect it.
I mean I think people get it in their gut but we need to put it into action I mean I think the
L.G.B. dimness fully behind you and perhaps we can lend some resources as
we get some successes of late. I hope so. I'm thinking
about the pope.
I'm
very grateful that he spoke about global warming that was very helpful
because at the legitimize to a lot of people who were denying global warming.
But
and he's not part of the L.G.B. team
is that you know I think
is as long as he and all the other patriarchal religions
are saying that sex is in various ways that sex is
immoral unless it ends in conception then we're going
to continue
to grow the single biggest cause cause of global
warming which is the load of the overload of
human beings on
earth born because not because women chose but
because they couldn't choose right.
So I you know
I I'd love to talk to him and say you
know. I agree with you but here's what you're doing
that's undermining what you care about you
know and just to be clear that he did not have a private meeting with Kim
Davis' fundraisers. Thankee by
famous.
This is more of a comment and a question I've been a college professor for forty four years.
I expect to make it to around
fifty and so I've seen the movement happen in from it's almost as earliest
days until now at the very beginning of my career might my women students
would ask me whether I believed this was their language whether I believed in the women's
movement because it's like gravity. You know. There it is it's not one doesn't believe
or disbelieve it simply is about twenty years ago I was
hearing things that went more like this I'm not a feminist
but also from my women students and I just cut them off and said yes
you
want your hear your in a university you're getting an education. What do
you think feminism is. I was prompted to get out of my seat
now to come forward because I was watching the line.
Of young people everyone who spoke
and half my age who you
find were find because of you trying because of you and were fine because all
those kids. Sorry kids all those young people got up and spoke about their
passion in this world and I personally feel great that to you because you
came just a little bit before me you were my
beacon and I tried to pass it along as well so thank you so much for being who
you are and for setting the
bar
lul
thank you and thank you for Project thank you for making a place
of growth in your classroom and for all the young people like that want to know so
I do you
you lose my question is not unrelated. What should
I say to decent men whom I love who are afraid of the word
feminism send them to the
dictionary to say that they're wrong.
Send them to the
dictionary and they will say is they will see the feminist I mean we all know we
can say it in unison is just a person male or female who believes in the full social
economic political equality of men and women males and females that's
it so because a lot of their disapproval is probably based
on misunderstanding of what it actually means.
And if it is based on. Understanding what it
means get rid of
them. Thank
you Thank you Lou Thank
you you so I waited all this time in the back the one you
clearly have the courage to do so.
Should that happen. Thank
you. Thank you
you'll be OK all right but don't forget I mean
I think we're out of time right OK so you don't have to do this if you don't have to
do anything. OK that you don't want to do
but why not introduce yourself to a couple of people you don't
know while you're here and who knows what might happen.
THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR.